Bei den Higgs-Teilchen war es genauso: Schon
Monate im Voraus zeichnete sich die sensationelle
Entdeckung an - durch erste schwache Trends
in den Daten.
Und auch jetzt befinden sich die Forschungsteam
am CERN nahe Genf wieder in so einer Phase
des Bangen und Hoffens.
Denn es gibt immer mehr Hinweise auf ein neues
spektakuläres Teilchen.
Die entsprechenden Daten stammen vom LHCb
- das ist eines der vier großen Experimente
am Teilchenbeschleuniger “Large Hadron Collider”
(LHC).
Alles über die neue Spur eines unbekannten
Teilchens jetzt hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction,
Hier gibt es täglich aktuelle Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen.
Und wieder einmal: Herzlichen Dank für diesen
spannenden Themenvorschlag aus Eurer Whats
App Community.
Das LHCb-Experiment am Teilchenbeschleuniger
LHC nahe Genf ist spezialisiert auf die Beobachtung
von seltenen Teilchenzerfällen.
Das b hinter LHC steht für übrigens für
beauty (LHCb = Large Hadron Collider beauty).
Der entsprechende Detektor des Experiments
ist auf den Nachweis der sogenannten B-Mesonen,
die zur Klasse der Hadronen gehören und eine
negative Elementarladung haben, getrimmt.
Denn diese enthalten die Beauty-Quarks, die
untersucht werden sollen.
Im Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik bilden
Quarks die elementaren Bestandteile, aus denen
Protonen und Neutronen aufgebaut sind.
Das Besondere an den Beauty-Hadronen ist,
dass sie bis zu zwei Zentimeter weit im Detektor
fliegen, ehe sie in weitere Teilchen zerfallen.
In dem LHCb-Detektor finden in jeder Sekunde
zehn Millionen Proton-Proton-Kollisionen statt.
Eine Aufzeichnung dieser zahlreichen Ereignisse
ist nicht möglich, denn das gibt der Speicherplatz
einfach nicht her.
Und so wird in Echtzeit entschieden, welches
Ereignis interessant ist.
Das übernimmt ein sogenanntes Triggersystem,
das durch zwei Filterschritte herausfinden
kann, ob ein Ereignis ein Beauty-Hadron enthält
und das analysiert werden sollte.
Konkret ist der LHCb-Detektor ein Vorwärtsspektrometer:
Auf 20 Metern entlang des Stahlrohres sind
seine Sub-Detektoren aufgebaut.
Seine Komponenten befinden sich nicht zwiebelartig
um den Kollisionspunkt herum, sondern sind
nur auf einer Seite des Wechselwirkungspunktes
um das Stahlrohr angeordnet - und zwar kegelförmig.
Am Kollisionspunkt befindet sich der erste
Subdetektor von LHCb; die anderen folgen auf
einer Länge von 20 Metern.
Neben seiner Länge von 21 Metern, ist der
Detektor 13 Meter breit und 10 Meter hoch.
An dem Experiment sind knapp 1.200 Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschftlerinnen aus 16 Ländern beteiligt
- unter anderem auch drei Institutionen aus
Deutschland.
Im Großen und Ganzen geht es hier um große
Fragen der Physik und des Lebens, um Materie
und Antimaterie.
Unser Universum besteht ja hauptsächlich
aus Materie.
Doch wie kann das sein?
Schließlich gehen wir davon aus, dass beim
Urknall Antimaterie und Materie in derselben
Menge erzeugt worden ist.
Jetzt wurden jedenfalls einige Datensätze
durch das LHCb-Experiment gewonnen, die auf
spektakuläre Erkenntnisse Hoffen lassen.
Denn als die Forschungsteams den Zerfall der
Hadronen untersucht hatten, gab es Abweichungen
zum Standardmodell.
Und das bildet die Säulen für die gesamte
Teilchenphysik.
Schon jetzt gibt es vage Vermutungen, was
hinter den Abweichungen stecken könnte.
Ist es vielleicht endlich die Existenz der
Leptoquarks, die man damit nachweisen kann?
In der Theorie wurden sie schon in den 80-er
Jahren vorhergesagt, doch bis heute konnte
man sie in der Praxis nicht nachweisen.
Falls das geschehen würde, wäre dies eine
Revolution in der Physik.
Leptoquarks sollen nämlich Quarks, also die
Atomkerne der Materie, in Leptonen, also leichte
Teilchen, umwandeln können.
Elektronen gehören beispielsweise zu den
Leptonen, genau wie das Myon und das Tau-Teilchen.
Doch solch eine Umwandlung von Quarks in Leptonen
ist nach dem Standardmodell eigentlich gar
nicht möglich.
Bisher gibt es einfach KEINE Verbindung zwischen
Quarks und Leptonen.
Eine neue Physik müsste dann also her - ihr
seht also, wie spektakulär das Ganze ist.
Und tatsächlich würde der Beweis des bisher
noch nicht entdeckten Leptoquark eine große
ungeklärte Frage beantworten: Warum ist der
Wert der negativen Ladung eines Elektrons
genau so groß wie die positive elektrische
Ladung eines Protons, das aus drei Quarks
besteht?
Endlich würde man dann durch die Entdeckung
der Leptoquarks auch ein Stück weit die so
lang erwünschte Supersymmetrie (Susy) untermauern
können.
Die Theorie, dass es zu jedem Teilchen ein
zweites Teilchen gibt und sie ineinander umwandelbar
sind.
Doch nicht alle Forschungsteams sind optimistisch,
dass die Entdeckung des Leptoquarks durch
das LHCb-Experiment kurz bevor steht.
Denn die Abweichungen in den Daten könnten
auch andere Dinge ans Tageslicht bringen.
Beispielsweise die Entdeckung eines Bosons,
das eine neue physikalische Kraft vermittelt.
Wirken würde sie vor allem auf Tauonen, weniger
auf Myonen und kaum oder gar nicht auf Elektronen.
Der Name des Bosons steht jetzt schon fest:
“Z”: UAber auch das wäre ein Sensationsfund!
Wenn ihr diesen Fund nicht verpassen wollt
und usner Video dazu, dann abonniert auch
den englischen Kanal.
Dafür einfach hier klicken, denn manchmal
kommen auch da Videos zuerst.
Und darunter geht es weiter mit: “Sensation
at the CERN: A Portal to a new kind of physics
has been opened!”
Ich freue mich, wenn wir uns auch auf dem
englischen Clixoom-kanal wiedersehen.
Stay tuned see you soon!